last st. Patrick's Day our incredible
costume department made us a shamrock
costume for a sketch that we were gonna
do and then we didn't end up doing the
sketch okay it happens all the time
sometimes things don't meet our high
standards well
knock it off anyway I said don't worry
we'll use the costume next year and I
meant it I just found out it turns out
st. Patrick's Day falls on Saturday this
year when we're not shooting our show
yeah so it's not st. Patty's Day yet but
I thought screw it our costume designer
did a lot of work on this got chronic
and I want to keep my promise please
welcome our costume designer Scott
chronic a shamrock sketch was supposed
to go with a free hosting pending patent
reversal and cut the Shamrock down it
stayed in the closet from now
[Applause]
so Scott how does it feel to finally
show off this shamrock costume to the
entire world
oh just thrilling yeah and didn't you
didn't you also build a Taco Bell
costume you worked really hard on a Taco
Bell costume that we never use I did all
right he did these are both real
costumes we paid for and they were not
used okay so all right now I just
occurred to me that the writers also
wrote something and again this is 100%
true they wrote a sketch called icicle
on a bicycle we never used it let's get
Madi
by the second way Cattlemen's advice now
is ever more seen shamrock Taco Bell
icicle on a bicycle costumes
you